-Ah, you're a stud.
-What's going on?
-Welcome.
You're making your late-night
talk show debut.
-Yes. What's up, y'all?
-This is your debut tonight.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Thank you for choosing
our show.
We appreciate that.
I know you were here actually
performing.
You've performed on the show.
-Yes. On that stage.
-Yeah.
-Over there. Yes.
-You were in the cast of
"Ain't Too Proud."
-"Ain't Too Proud." My boys.
-This is 2019 right there.
And this was -- I remember
this show, the Temptations.
-Yes.
-This was opening night?
-God, it was opening night.
Our producers thought it was
a great idea for us to be here,
get in an old Cadillac and drive
to our opening night
on 46th Street.
What they didn't realize was
in this old Cadillac was
a lot of dust, so as we're
riding from here to 46th,
all the boys, we start to have
allergy attacks and our throats
start closing up.
-Oh, my God.
-We start to panic.
-You're kidding me.
-One that I'll never forget.
-Yeah.
Gosh, why would you do that
on opening night?
-Why would you do that to us?
-I'm so sorry.
-It's okay.
-But thank you for doing that.
You went on to be nominated for
a Tony, so there you go.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Not too shabby.
Actually, you also got nominated
for another Tony that night,
right?
Was it "Ain't Too Proud" --
-At the same time, yeah.
-At the same time.
And "Choir Boy."
-Yeah.
-What was the Tonys like
for you?
Were you just like "This is it"?
-The Tonys was a blur.
I mean, my parents were there.
They were so very proud of me.
But it was like a marathon.
I was like running from one side
of the stage to the other side
of the stage at Radio City.
I kinda blacked out, hoping that
I didn't win because I had
nothing to say.
I wouldn't know who to thank.
-Yeah. But you have
very supportive parents?
-Very supportive.
-Do they come to your premieres?
-They do, they do.
My mom, who I love so dearly,
my Broadway debut, "Choir Boy,"
she passed out during the middle
of the show.
[ Audience aws ]
She's fine.
[ Laughter ]
-Did you see her pass out?
-No, it was one of those things
where, you know, we're doing
our, you know, our thing,
and we hear kind of on the God
mike from our stage manager,
"All actors exit the stage."
We do so.
They tell us, you know, someone
has passed out, they're okay.
So all the boys were kind of
like,
"Well, was it an old patron?
Like, how old are they?
Are they fine?"
-Of course, yeah.
-You know what I mean?
We go back, we finish the show.
It was all of our Broadway
debuts, so it was
my brilliant idea for us to walk
out with "Hi, Mom" signs
because all of our moms
are there.
I'm looking out for mine.
I'm assuming she's there.
I get off the stage, and I see
my brother and stepdad there,
and they're like, "It was Mom
who passed out."
[ Laughter ]
And really, she just got so
excited and nervous, I guess,
moms when they watch their kids
on stage, she didn't want me
to be nervous, so she wanted to
take all of the nerves.
[ Laughter ]
-And she's proud of you.
-She's very proud of me.
Apparently as soon as she got up
from, you know, seeing Jesus
Christ, she came back and --
[ Laughter ]
Apparently she said,
"Tell them I'm not going."
So my mom was in an ambulance
outside of the theater,
and I was able to give her a hug
and love,
and she made it to the
after-party, so all is good.
-Wow.
-Yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-That's interesting.
You were in "Ain't Too Proud,"
and then your mom was actually
too proud.
-She was so proud.
-Yeah, she was.
-She got too proud.
Exactly. Yeah.
I want to talk about,
you're going back to Broadway.
-Yes.
-Here you are right here
with "The Collaboration."
You play Basquiat.
-Basquiat.
Is that Paul Bettany
as Andy Warhol?
-It is.
-And you did this in London?
-Yes. It's been a journey with
this project.
We went to London
at the Young Vic Theatre.
We just wrapped the movie
last weekend, and we are in
rehearsals for the Broadway
production right now.
-That's wild.
-Yeah, yeah.
-He's such an interesting guy
from what I've read.
-Yeah, he's such a beautiful,
mysterious spirit.
And the story just follows
the two of them, Andy Warhol
and Basquiat
and the collaboration they did
in the '80s in New York.
-Yeah.
-So, you know, we're just having
a really good time.
I love Paul so much,
and it's just been, you know,
a once-in-a-lifetime experience
to do it
in three different iterations.
And it keeps evolving,
it keeps evolving.
So I'm just excited to bring it
to New York.
-Performances start
November 29th
at the Samuel J. Friedman
Theatre.
Congratulations on doing this.
Let's talk about
"The Inspection."
-"The Inspection."
-You're getting great reviews
for this one.
If you want to plug your ears,
I'm just gonna talk about you
for a second.
"Pope gives a career-igniting
performance in the role."
That was Variety.
"Pope seems primed for movie
stardom with this turn."
The Wrap. What?
[ Cheers and applause ]
Not too shabby, bud.
Tony Awards. Come on.
All the awards.
-It's a blessing.
It's a blessing.
-Good for you.
This is based on a true story.
Can you set up what this is?
-Yes, it's based off
of the experiences of
the writer/director
Elegance Bratton.
He was kicked out of his house
by his mother for being gay
and lived homeless for about
15 years and didn't have
too many options, but the option
he decided to go with was join
the Marines in an attempt to win
his mother's love and affection.
He finds self-love,
self-worthiness.
It's a story that challenges
masculinity
and what it means to be
yourself.
We shot it
in Jackson, Mississippi,
last year in 19 days.
It was very hot.
-Yeah.
-But I'm so proud of this film.
It was made with
such a labor of love.
A24, Gamechanger Films.
My cast was incredible.
Gabrielle Union, Bokeem
Woodbine, Raul Castillo.
I love them so much.
So we're kind of -- we've been
able to take it to festivals,
New York Film Festival, TIFF.
-When you do a movie like this
and it's realistic,
do you have to train for this?
-Yeah, well, this one
specifically, boot camp.
I've never served
in the military,
so we had some pretty intense
boot camp.
I remember there was one
morning, you know, we had done
our readthrough and we got,
you know, our call sheet
and it said 3:30 a.m. pickup.
And I was like, "P.M. or A.M.?"
[ Laughter ]
And it was A.M.
And it was because we were going
out to basically do
all of the push-ups
and all of the running.
-So you get a real feel
of the character.
-To get a real feel of
what it's like.
And I just wanted to remind
everyone, I'm an actor.
[ Laughter ]
I want to learn how to act it.
-"I'm acting.
I'm not actually
in the military.
I'm acting like I'm in."
You did a very convincing job.
I want to show everyone a clip.
Here's Jeremy Pope
in "The Inspection."
Take a look at this.
-My mom.
She won't even talk to me.
Most of my friends
are dead or in jail.
The streets is going to kill me
no matter what,
so if I die in this uniform...
...I'm a hero to somebody.
-Oof.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Jeremy Pope!
"The Inspection" opens
in select theaters
this Friday,
nationwide December 2nd.
Thank you so much, bud.
Come back, please, okay?
Bruce Springsteen performs
for us after the break!
Stick around, everybody.